on a tendance à penser que lorsque on
débat il ya un espèce de standards égale
qui doit s'appliquer à tout le monde et
ça ça apparaît quelque chose
d'extrêmement important d'autant que
d'habitude lorsque l'on à un débat on a
tendance intuitivement à avoir plutôt
une sorte de double standard ou
malencontreusement on a tendance à
exiger plus de l'interlocuteur qu'on
exige de nous mêmes et ça c'est quelque
chose de finalement assez problématique
puisque inévitablement chacun des
interlocuteurs à exiger plus de l'autre
et ça va amener très probablement un
conte critique
quelque chose que j'ai pu tester
empiriquement notamment au moment du
fameux débat entre les étés titien et
les journalistes en essayant de voir
comment chacun des camps percevait c'est
la manière dont ils avaient attaqué
l'autre notamment à ce qu'il y avait de
la virulence qui avait été exprimée par
un camp ou alors c'était un peu
difficile parce que forcément à cette
édition puisque répondu que les
journalistes mais dans les réponses aux
sondages que j'avais fait on observe
assez clairement qu' il ya eu un écart
entre la violence reçu là entre la
perception de la violence reçu la
perception de la violence exprimée
c'est ce qu'on appelle la
rationalisation le biais de confirmation
on a tendance à être beaucoup plus
critique
deux des autres des intuitions des
autres que l'on est critique de nos
propres intuitions et ça forcément pour
rien débattre
ça paraît vraiment pas top et du cou
éviter notamment la rationalisation de
l'interlocuteur on a tendance ensuite à
exiger que tout le monde débattent sont
les mêmes règles on a tendance à vouloir
être un petit peu autoritaire sur la
manière de débattre et ça en fait si on
y réfléchit c'est pas forcément super
tip top puisque les personnes à qui on
exige ce même standard de débats vont se
sentir un peu offensé vont se sentir un
peu attaquées et le réflexe naturel qui
vient après cela ça risque d'être de la
défense un mode soldats voire de
l'hooliganisme et du coup il semble qu
exiger le même standard pour tout le
monde
avoir un seul standard en fait c'est
quelque chose qui en pratique ne marche
pas forcément très bien plutôt que d'un
double standard et où d'un standard
unique
en fait il semble utile de déployer un
espèce de double standard inversé c'est
à dire être finalement beaucoup plus
exigeants avec nous-mêmes qu'on ne l'ait
avec autrui et en particulier avec
l'interlocuteur
et oui ça c'est la suite de la rando
petit passage dans un long tunnel
bon on se voit l'autre côté du tunnel
alors on pratique le double standard
inversé c'est quoi l'activisme c'est
sauter sur la première occasion pour
reconnaître que l'autre à raison pour
être d'accord explosion peut-être notre
accord avec l'autre pour signaler que
l'autre a bien raisonné et al'inverse
être beaucoup beaucoup plus tolérant des
erreurs des autres ne pas et soulevées
si elles ne sont pas graves
et même quand on est s'élève montré que
de façon très bienveillante
il s'agit d'une erreur que beaucoup de
gens très intelligents de fond et qui a
aucune honte à les faire et à linverse
quand on a raison de ne pas le signaler
ton est un argument particulièrement
brillant ne pas se vanter d'avoir eu cet
argument particulièrement brillant et
quand on a tort le signal et dire qu'on
s'est vraiment trompé et s'excuser aussi
vite que possible et de façon assez
contre intuitive en fait plus le débat
est difficile où le des personnes
malveillantes délicat plus il semble
important d'appliquer ce double standard
inversée et de faire en sorte que l'on
mette
en avant les bons côtés du côté opposé
et comment surtout si le débat bien et
qu'on soit très critique de notre façon
de débattre et ce qui est dit là d'un
point de vue individuel semble
s'appliquer au niveau du groupe oc sont
que trop souvent dans les débats entre
groupes polarisée on a tendance à avoir
un double standard non l'inversé donc un
mauvais double standard et une sangle
qui serait intéressant d'avoir au
contraire un double standard inversée
pour créer du lien et aider plus
facilement les gens à passer du mode
hooligans mode bienveillant et avoir des
débats plus constructif je pense qu'on
peut aller plus loin que le double
s'endort inversé on peut aller vers le
triple standard merci voir le quadruple
standard inversée voir un continuum de
stands à renverser tout simplement en
prenant en compte d'autres facteurs donc
typiquement une somme que quand le débat
est public il est d'autant plus
important d'avoir de traiter l'autre de
façon ultra bienveillante et être
vraiment beaucoup plus tolérants de ses
erreurs et signalé beaucoup plus ce qui
fait de bien et de la même façon quand
on débat de façon de public je pense que
c'est encore je viens important de
signaler ses propres erreurs de pour
calmer autant que possible le débat en
particulier si vous voulez avoir un
débat qui va beaucoup plus rapidement
sur les pneus du débat sur les points
chauds du débat il semble beaucoup bien
préférable de faire ça davantage en
privé où il est plus raisonnable de
s'autoriser quelque chose qui est moins
exacerbée dans la logique du double
standard inversé c'est à dire on peut
être un peu plus un niveau égal
il me semble que vraiment en public
c'est vraiment important d'avoir ces
standards à verser c'est à dire être
beaucoup plus critique de nous-mêmes et
beaucoup plus bienveillants l'autre
ceci dit on peut se demander si le
double standard inverser ses variantes
sont vraiment efficaces pour faire
avancer un débat il me semble que la
réponse est assez généralement
possiblement wii ou très probablement
oui je pense que ça peut aider parce que
notamment
ça permet de détacher les débats de cet
aspect très confrontation elle qui
éveille un peu les williams chez les uns
et les autres et qui empêche la
réflexion mais également ça peut
encourager des bonnes habitudes à
prendre c'est que les humains fonctionne
beaucoup par imitation ou par
conformisme et du coup si on s'habitue à
débattre avec des gens qui ont
l'habitude de beaucoup mettre en avant
leurs propres erreurs et de reconnaître
ce que l'autre fait de bien c'est ce
genre de truc peut devenir un peu plus
une norme de débats dont quelqu'un il
sent que si tout le monde sait ça l'a
clairement très très très probablement
la qualité des débats va grandement
augmenté donc il s'agit pas juste
d'appliquer les doubles standards
inversée pour que les débats soient plus
gentille et bienveillant je pense que
c'est vraiment une façon d'améliorer
significativement surtout sur le long
terme la qualité de nos débats